alors vous avez pas eu beaucoup
mais en fait c'est une époque où quand
j'étais très contente parce que mon ex
donc m'avait invité il m'invitait pas
souvent parce qu'il était connu et marié
alors il m'avait invité au restaurant et
j'étais tellement contente en fait
j'étais un peu comme de Dominique
Farrugia dans la cité de la peur quand
j'étais contente j'étais malade et je
vomissais donc
j'ai vomi sur le canapé
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
j'étais énervé et donc voilà
j'ai vomi sur ses chaussures
le gars il avait les yep avec du vomi
sur la tête de ma mère qu'elle over mon
frère
tiens casse-toi alors moi alors j'étais
au Japon j'étais au Japon pour faire des
affaires qui ne se sont jamais faites
comme d'habitude et j'ai été en fait tu
vas toujours nous raconter un truc
au départ mais après ça va être drôle
par contre tu croyais que tu allais
faire des affaires au Japon
c'est toujours et donc j'avais rencontré
deux charmantes personnes
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment un connard hein et donc
ce serait bien de d'aller dans un très
grand restaurant
japonais ou on mange du très très bon
poisson des des moi je voulais manger
des sushis des alchimie sauf que là-bas
au Japon le poisson cru il y a des
pièces de poissons qui valent une
fortune et quand je vais devenir c'est
près de 7000 euros le kilos ça fait du
thon rouge c'est un ton particulier et
donc moi je savais pas que ça coté et le
taureau je crois quoi là et donc c'est
sympa on peut on va commander des des
sushis des Sachs chimiques sauf que le
sushi le sushi un sushi c'était 300
balles 300 euros
maintenant je te jure que c'est vrai
et donc moi alors on va faire un
assortiment et l'addition l'addition
l'addition de cette connerie de dîner là
connerie de Didier 12000 euros
[Applaudissements]
mais par contre je vous jure que c'est
vrai c'est le meilleur poisson que j'ai
mangé de toute ma vie
exceptionnel ça c'était incroyable
saumon sur la tête j'ai mangé un saumon
ah je crois
le saumon truc j'ai vu je l'ai mangé
avant après j'ai vu c'est quoi ceci
alors et toi moi c'est à quelques années
à l'époque où j'étais un ignoble Charo
donc j'ai sympathisé avec une fille sur
Instagram et de fil en aiguille je
l'invite à dîner au restaurant
donc je me pointe au restaurant et là je
vois qu'elle avait quelqu'un elle me dit
Guillaume je te présente mon mec Michael
quoi
[Rires]
reculer le mec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur les deux d'avance
une semaine au ski on lui a manqué comme
un coucou
de Funès
pour les dates en revanche une fois il y
a longtemps j'avais fait un dîner dans
un restaurant indien qui s'appelle Lana
Purna je sais pas si vous connaissez
dans le 8e c'est un très bon restaurant
on est assis au sol il y a un joueur de
cithare à l'entrée qui est pieds nus un
très beau monsieur avec une barbe
blanche et c'est très très triste
et donc plutôt très épicé je sais pas si
vous avez vu le film poli et moi avec
Ben Stiller effectivement comment des
trucs très très épicés et la personne a
passé finalement le repas aux chiottes
et ouais parce que il avait une sorte de
diarrhée fulgurante très très fort et en
fait je n'ai pas vu de la soirée je suis
resté tout seul en fait à tête avec
moi-même ce qu'on appelle une garrigue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je pense qu'il devrait y avoir une
règle au niveau de smoothie faudrait
aller aux toilettes pour se moucher
c'est quoi c'est comme ça
j'ai déjà eu un rendez-vous le gars
c'est moche une fois j'ai dit ok bon on
peut dire que c'est une erreur faut pas
être voilà faut pas trop regarder et au
bout du deuxième mouchoir j'ai envoyé un
message à ma meilleure amie et je lui
dis appelle-moi je me barre
mais une meuf moi qui se mouche devant
moi
elle est malade
à la limite elle vomit
elle se mouche non non je suis d'accord
mais vous aimez pas les Dinan face à
face de toute façon
donc ici vous pouvez dîner avec personne
en fait enfin si peut-être Kelly Valérie
et moi voilà
c'est le mec il est il arrive vers le
client
il vient comme ça il a le pouce rentrer
dans le steak le client a dit dis donc
vous êtes dégueulasse mettez votre pouce
dans mon steak et toi tu dis bah ouais
mais ça fait deux fois qu'il tombe par
terre
[Applaudissements]
il est en pleine forme Raymond alors moi
c'était un dîner où il y avait trois
mecs et 3 à 3 nanas et j'ai la plus
belle des nanas qui se met en face de
moi je suis content j'ai j'ai pu
border nouilles c'est magnifique elle
arrêtait pas de postillonner quand elle
parlait vraiment je te jure elle m'a
envoyé des postillons à manger des
frites un moment donné j'ai un bout de
pomme de terre je dis rien tu as vu j'ai
rien dire je vais rien dire je pose de
bout de pomme de terre par terre c'est
en train de me massacrer mais je peux
rien dire tu vois je cherche et elle
rentre tout ce que j'aime
bien c'est vrai que personne à la roté
deux fois de suite j'ai pas de chance
les autres qui sont mis là ils ont là
moi j'ai décroché le pompon elle se met
un gros de camionneur
c'est le coca elle me dit c'est le
coquin
mes potes ils sont morts de rire bah à
la base vous étiez
tu payes l'addition franchement
et elle est partie aux toilettes au plus
d'un quart d'heure c'est obligé ces
grosses commissions
pendant 20 minutes il y avait personne
en face du site
alors moi je suis une époque je donnais
mes rendez-vous galant dans le quartier
Saint-Michel à Paris avec spécialité de
fruits et légumes et notamment de melon
une jolie histoire grave erreur
excuse-moi mais déjà ça commence mal
franchement déjà
les années 90 et de l'autre côté juste à
côté du fait de long vous voyez sur la
place Saint Michel
et donc c'est grave erreur parce que il
y a quelques années j'ai fait une
indigestion au melon mais voilà et donc
on commence pourquoi vous riez mon
histoire en plus et donc du coup c'est
vraiment la chaîne
on fait un bec à dos et tout ça on
discute et il a demoiselle prend je
l'avais rencontré sur 36-15 Aline par
minitel
c'est que la meuf est déjà loin
[Applaudissements]
et donc voilà donc elle prend un melon
parce que je l'encourage c'est un
spécialité locale et je ne sais pas
pourquoi vous savez que parfois j'ai
tendance à parler trop je lui raconte
que j'ai eu le melon c'est bien mais moi
j'en mange plus j'ai une indigestion etc
et j'ai vu son visage se figer etc et au
bout d'un moment elle a commencé à ne
pas éructer mais vomir le melon qu'elle
était en train de manger elle est partie
aux toilettes plus qu'un quart d'heure
très longuement et donc je suis descendu
après parce qu'elle revenait plus et
elle était restée avec toilettes elle
m'a dit moi je reste dans les toilettes
tu payes tu te barres et j'ai obéi elle
est restée doucement
contredire mais tu ne les a dit c'est la
spécialité le melon c'est-à-dire c'est
spécial le melon se cultive à Saint
Michel
non mais il était très bon très frais
très très réputé
de merde
pourquoi moi
une histoire de ouf comme ça
fait 100 ans que j'ai pas fait et vous
c'est quoi votre pire date au restaurant
5e moi je me rappelle une meuf moi jouer
au rite
[Rires]
j'ai vraiment mais vous vous aurez
vraiment des trucs de ouf je sais pas
qui vous fréquentez hein l'autre elle
chie des melons l'autre il va chier des
normes
sans déconner franchement vous êtes des
fous de l'hôtel elle envoie des chips
dans la gueule
sans déconner vous êtes où il y a le
petit mousse Commission des lèvres ça
c'est dégueulasse comme les garçons il
arrive il dit vous avez choisi la 2
petits pois de mousse ce qui bouillonne
à la commission d'élèves là tu dis bah
vous savez quoi en tout cas ça fait
plaisir d'aller manger merci